just to remind folks where we were
when you look back
at the house DNA committee that met in
February we had a recommendation that
came out of the ENA committee for
interim study and that vote
um did come out of the house unanimously
and then it did go on the house floor as
a Voice vote for interim study
um and we did feel that
it was important for us to take another
look here at it ask some questions and
hear from folks who had
and hear from folks who had uh
stakeholder input thank you
um so with that I will look to either
one of my two colleagues here to
um also ask any questions should they
have any
great so um for the author of the The
Bill representative partial if you
wouldn't mind uh coming up and for the
record just stating your name
thank you
yes I have partial representing marble
and Troy currently
representative I have had the chance to
take a look at uh pieces of legislation
um that are germane that have that have
um
that are either in the process or are
continuing to work through the
legislatures in other neighboring states
and I am curious to know
um sort of how
the formation of of the charge of the
commission was formed
and so if you could speak to that I
noticed that you have two members of the
House a member of the Senate
and a member of Des one member of North
East resource recovery Association a
member of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and a member of
Northeast Recycling council do do you
have any other thoughts about the
composition of that proposed Commission
not necessarily although I think that we
should have all interested stakeholders
present and if there were
advocates for other systems Beyond uh
um
Beyond uh extended producer
responsibility and perhaps their voices
should be heard
questions that um
do or do not um include producer
stakeholders so that's one one entity
that I was noticing that was perhaps not
named directly in the charge of the
commission and I didn't know if that was
intentional or if that is
um if you had thoughts as to why why
that was the way it was I will I'll
quickly admit that was not intentional I
think that it's important to have a
broad swath of Representatives
um
I just could not find a
a lobbyist group I guess you'd say that
would advocate for
um or against
the situation
okay thank you representative
yes thank you so much
the question I had was what what was the
impetus for you to feel like that that
we should be looking towards our waste
reduction goals right now for extended
producer
UH responsibilities just what how do you
feel at this point not how do you feel
but what is your information on
um our waste reduction
abilities now my information uh beyond
what uh our 1990 study was in waste
reduction
was that speaking with my local uh
Municipal board and with the local
transfer station
and they are both very deeply concerned
about this issue I imagine met very many
Municipal boards are
um
China we have we no longer have a source
for our for much of our disposables
um and you know there's two aspects of
this one is the packaging and the other
is
the actual products that we dispose of
and speaking of the packaging
um
we have mandatory recycling in Marlboro
but once we collect it it really does
not get uh there's no place to put it
about nine bottles on average just say
these soda bottles example about nine
bottles out of 100 actually get recycled
the rest end up in our landfill
and uh
it's just um
so it was so the impetus for this to
answer your question I think would be
that it was a local concern of my town
uh in in the bill in for the study
committee you
um discussed RSA 149 Dash M with you
know emphasis on Improvement of
Municipal recycling what are those goals
what are the goals in that RSA
I don't have that right okay so all
right let me look it up real quick and
I'll uh
let's see here
it looks like the goals it says here are
by the year 2000 is to achieve a 40
minimum weight diversion of solid waste
landfill or incineration per on per
capita basis that was in 1999. do you
have any do you have any actual data on
from 1999 to
you know this was in a year so this is
effective 1999 in the
looks like the the RSA said in a year
we're going to achieve a 40 we have
fallen far short of that well I I guess
I don't understand that the gold you
know the impetus of how that goal was
even made because I'm not sure anybody
could make a one-year goal of reducing
something by 40 percent
do you know how this has been taken
seriously in any way RSA 149 colon m
M oh I do not okay
thank you representative for the
question uh just a point of
clarification
I just wanted to clarify I I have
participated myself in solid waste
recycling study committee
um in the year 2019 where four members
sat on that committee and there is
currently the solid waste working group
that is underway so I did have some
questions with regard to some of the
charges within this bill and I was
curious to know about whether or not
starting on line 20 to 22.
um the charges
um here talk about the emphasis of
improving Municipal recycling solid
waste flow and the reduction of taxpayer
costs and the support of transfer
stations throughout extended producing
responsibility
um and while while that
um is certainly germane to this I'm
curious to know if there are additional
things that you might include in the
charge of something that was solely
focused on extended producer
responsibility well my personal opinion
is that a project of this magnitude
is sufficient to itself and while I
think solved waste reduction group
programs
need to be part of this and I think that
we need to use every approach every tool
that is available to us
I do see this particular bill as
something that is attacking a
individual
unique situation that we can make
progress with therefore I recommend the
scope of a study group to be limited to
this extended producer responsibility
follow up if I'm going to recognize
myself for a follow-up so so with that
you're really looking at the packaging
the way materials are packaged in the
state of New Hampshire or and the reason
I asked sorry the reason I do ask is
um that extended producer responsibility
generally speaking has a very unique
lens and it looks at pretty specific
portions of how we manage our solid
waste
um
um yes I I'm not looking at this as a
packaging Bill although I think that can
have a significant impact but I also
know that we uh currently
um we have tipping fees on many of our
electronic products and the like uh
tires there was a bill this passed a
bionum to uh uh build in cost of solar
panel um disposal
um
I think these are all valid concerns and
while my particular emphasis is on
the waste that's being produced I cannot
turn a blind eye to uh those other very
significant factors in our landfills as
well some are very toxic in fact and
they do need this attention
thank you and I I do notice that there's
somebody from the Department of
Environmental Services here so um you're
welcome to sort of
um I'd like to recognize the department
for a moment if that's that's okay
you're welcome to come sit at this other
chair so that you have a microphone we
can learn to be
it's a big room for us
thank you um
Mr wimsat uh if you wouldn't mind for
the record just stating your name and
the department
my name is
service director underway Community
provision for the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
thank you um
one of the things that I would like to
sort of discuss and hear your thoughts
um is uh about the formation of a
commission such as this and as we know
that the difference in a commission is
obviously that there is generally
stakeholder input and I did notice the
original version did not have producer
stakeholders involved in the
conversation and we were just briefly
commenting that that is probably an
important part of the conversation
um to include but my thoughts are
on the larger sort of scope of this uh
as it relates to the charge that we saw
below do you feel that there are any
redundancies or overlaps and what is
going on currently with the solid waste
working group
um well that that that's a fair question
if I if I may uh just as a point of
clarification before we talk about that
the representative looked online to look
at the reduction goal in the statute and
I think things are a little behind on
that because the there was a reduction
goal that was it was completely changed
more recently within the last couple of
years and that's at RSA 149 M2 and it
basically has been updated and I'll just
if I may describe it briefly to
establish a goal to reduce disposable
Municipal solid waste and construction
demolition debris by 25 by 2030 and 45
by 2050. so the
um the the goal that the representative
was doing was an older one that has been
supplanted now so okay great
um so so those are very relevant and
current and I and I I think this this
particular uh work session is timely in
the sense that we just issued an updated
Solid Waste Management plan last Friday
um September 30th uh which should which
uh has a lot of language which which
basically sets out broad
um uh goals strategies and actions that
we intend to take over the next 10 years
to try to as among many things but
really as a focus to try to achieve that
reduction goal that's been established
that waste reduction goal and um
part of that will certainly be and
you'll see in the in the text of the
plan our interest in exploring
legislation on many things including
extended producer responsibility and
other methods of improving diversion
trying to get more certainly emphasizing
getting more infrastructure in the state
that's focused on non-disposal options
for Waste such as a materials recovery
facility for recyclables
more construction demolition debris
recycling facilities than we currently
have
compost and other technologies that we
really don't have right now such as
anaerobic digestion we do have some
composting facilities in the state for
food waste and organic waste but we need
many more so this is a very timely
discussion I think and certainly during
this session
um
New Hampshire Des didn't necessarily
take a position on this bill but we were
tracking it and um but I think that with
the uh published the publication of the
solid race management plan very recently
uh the idea of the legislature
assembling a commission to look at these
issues and I'll get to your question I
promise
um is is appropriate um and that perhaps
extended producer responsibility having
a commission that focuses on that is is
helpful because that's a really big even
though it's it's one sort of approach it
has very broad potential application for
a variety of products not just packaging
but other materials as well so I think
it in and of itself it's a it's a worthy
issue of study as far as uh whether the
how that overlaps potentially with the
current work of the solid waste working
group I I might defer to representative
evil who also chairs the solid waste
working group and I think with with her
in the room I might be inclined to to
allow her to address that question if
that's all right sure I'd allow that
thank you madam chair of the solid waste
working group yep uh good morning for
the record my name is Karen Ebel and I
represent Merrimack District Five New
London and Newbury and I am in fact the
chair of the solid waste working group
so I I think if I understood your
question correctly what you were trying
to get at is whether a commission that
was established to focus on
epr would be duplicative of work that
the solid waste working group was going
to be doing
um it's a it's a challenging question
because I really have to go back to the
solid waste working group and ask them
where they want to focus next
speaking for myself I think epr is way
up on the priority scale for analysis
we definitely want to focus on as they
say the front end of the pipe instead of
the back end of the pipe I was really
struck at a conference I attended
recently that
someone from a recycling
non-profit was talking about how for so
long
um consumers have been expected to be
the ones to have to deal with uh with
packaging that was produced and it was
sort of their problem and I think more
and more
manufacturers should be looked at to try
to help the situation with solid waste
by decreasing
decreasing the packaging that they're
producing focusing more on the
recyclability of it if it does go
through the pipe and and so I think
we'll be looking at epr but from a
timing standpoint I don't I'm not sure
exactly when that will happen
I do have one other comment I I did
share the hb61 seven recycling installed
waste study committee that was a
legislator only study committee not a
commission
I don't think anybody could say that
that was an unsuccessful
Endeavor
and honestly everybody who was
interested in the issue of solid waste
was given ample time to testify and
um
and they followed the situation all the
time so although it's important on the
one hand when you have a commission to
have various voices on the table it's
not like people can't participate on an
ongoing basis and
I thought the way we handled it was
really successful the only other thing
I'll say about commissions is that
whereas a legislative committee can come
together really quickly if you have a
commission that requires a lot of
appointments by different people it can
delay the the startup time so that's
just a consideration I appreciate the
perspective thank you one of the other
things that I was curious about is sort
of the
um I know that the New Hampshire
Municipal Association was named as a
stakeholder group here and I think there
might be somebody
nope there isn't actually
um and so but
um to which
to which to your point I think I I have
a question of of the impact that
extended producer responsibility has on
municipalities as well as the consumer
and I think that that relationship of
what happens uh to the refuse at the
municipal level is probably also an
important aspect to look into I don't
know if you would agree or not
yeah I definitely uh agree I have to say
when I first came at this issue
um in 2019 my overriding concern was the
effect of the um
the decision of China not to take a lot
of our Plastics and mixed paper and so I
mean I think the impact of all of this
is really really
um tough for for municipalities and if
they were able to deal with less refuse
I'm sure they would appreciate it
thank you
thank you so much
um I'm just trying to make sure that I'm
I'm understanding everything we're doing
today we're discussing whether we're
going to have a
we're studying if we're going to have a
study commission right just to make sure
we understand that that I understand
that
what I what I'd like to know is that
I'm we have goals on the books of what
our goals are that you all have goals
that you're working towards as well on
our behalf
the commission is looking at these at
waste reduction right now the committee
do we need a commission on top of that
or is that something since this as it's
been communicated that this is a
priority and this is something of Des
interest
why can't we have that conversation
and put it in the right priority without
an additional study Commission
because I the only reason I'm asking
it's not it's not to critique anything
it's just that I mean like say for
instance today we can't get a quorum
together because people are you know
time time time time is time
so isn't this something that can already
be discussed an important issue that can
be discussed under our current framework
of what we have right now
so I I don't want to speak for the solid
waste work group I'm a member of the
solid waste working group um that is an
August group it's 20 I think people that
represent all uh that was both
legislative representation and solid
waste industry environmental groups it
has a really broad
um broad spectrum of representation they
have a lot of work to do they have a lot
of topics and as representative has
indicated epr is definitely one of the
things that is high on the list I think
is what she said so I I don't think it's
des's place to say whether an extra
commission or the working group but from
my perspective as a member of the
working group
um I think it's certainly something that
that group could have a very informed
discussion on and could help to develop
some recommendations so I I think it can
certainly work within the context of the
solid waste working group
and again all I'm asking really and I
appreciate answering that all I'm trying
to get at is do we already have the
capability and and people in the room
that can have this discussion and put it
in the in the right priority because
even if we have a study commission that
handles this then whatever comes out of
that study commission is going right
back into the same pipeline that you all
are doing for implementation so it's
it's sort of like the talk can't keep up
with the action you know what I mean
um yes ma'am
um I actually think that this is going
to come up many times over the over the
next term because the the issue of solid
waste is really one that um
I'm pleased to say is getting a lot of
attention and I think
um people in the legislature are going
to have to decide whether they want to
have study committees that are going
forward while the solid waste working
group is working while Des is working on
its implementation plans
I I have I'm going to be honest I have
somewhat mixed feelings about it except
that
the solid waste working group you know
we had so many responsibilities anyway
it's a little bit my fault because I
wrote the Bill but
um uh we have accomplished one though we
have the long range plan out we have a
lot of responsibilities but we gained
even more responsibilities when
legislation was amended to create study
committees instead of going for you know
for us meaning for us to study more
um things so we just we're not going to
be able to do everything in the year
I mean I can't say that I think it would
be a bad idea for the legislature to
just sort of zero in on this issue and
and talk about it I mean I've I've had
another concept if you didn't want to
just go straight to us if you didn't
want to do a study committee you could
start with a bill and start working
um working in that direction I think epr
is a really really
important discussion for the state to
have because I feel like it should
appeal to
all parties
meaning political parties and views of
of you know and perspectives because
it's kind of a Yankee tradition that you
take responsibility for what you're
producing
um and I think it would be great to
focus at the front end of the pipe and
our and you know we can talk to people
in Maine and see how all that's going
if I may really quickly and then I I
will recognize you next So speaking of
Maine
um I have taken the time to look at um
with with
good intention uh and the extended
producer Responsibility program that
they have and it looks like parts of it
are being implemented currently it may
take almost the better part of seven to
ten years to fully Implement their
program
um and so what that tells me is that
there is a significant amount of
material that would need to be covered
in
um
the concept of extended producer
responsibility to make sure that we are
truly getting the full scope of what it
may entail and when I was asking some of
those questions that is
um to representative partial it is sort
of with that in mind and understanding
that this is not just necessarily about
packaging it involves many different
stakeholders and and too much to that
end I wanted to make sure that
if it went in the way of a commission
that that would not be duplicative but
also give folks the appropriate amount
of time to sort of
look at the situation fully
sure
thank you
thank you chair
um I I would also advocate for a
commission because this is a very
rapidly changing landscape we are
dealing with right now recently
California is a who is a very big player
thus came in with their own version of
the EPA epr
and Amazon has recently uh started uh
putting teeth into their requirement
that products being shipped to Germany
into France and some other places carry
the registration I I think that there's
a lot of moving Parts here and uh I will
be honest I do not understand all of
them I know this Solid Waste work has a
much deeper understanding than I do over
these uh various parts but I think a
study commission could address that on a
long term basis and get all the players
into one place and one other thing I
would like to add at some point is we
have today uh Bonnie Christie here and I
think she might be able to answer some
of your questions on the municipal
impact of uh
well that's what we're currently doing
thank you thank you I'd like to
recognize representative
oh sure thank you
um
representative
um partial had suggested that you might
have some input on the municipal sort of
aspect of things and so with that I'll
call you
up thank you
thank you I'm Bonnie Christie I'm from
Hopkinton and I am the chair of the
Hopkinton waste reduction committee and
I'm also on the Joint Committee with the
town of Webster we share a transfer
station and we have a overarching
committee that runs the operations of
the transfer station and I submitted
testimony in January on representative
partials bill 1111.
um from from the perspective of not not
having an opinion about
well an opinion that we could really
benefit in municipalities from epr
and I don't have an opinion on what form
because I know Maine has their own epr
and I believe Oregon has theirs I think
maybe Colorado past epr and it's pretty
individualized by the state
but what we're experiencing in Hopkinton
is I'm I'm sure is the same in all
municipalities our waste load is growing
and growing
and we do our best
with our staff to recycle we do
diversion recycle and we're working on
composting now we don't have that in
place yet but we're trying to divert
but even with all our efforts excuse me
our best efforts we can't keep up with
it and it's becoming more and more
expensive and until 2021 we paid 72
dollars a ton to dispose of our refuse
in the landfill or incinerator
and then it jumped ten dollars a ton in
the first year and every year it's going
up and up and up with our new contract
and we'll be paying about a hundred
dollars a ton in 2025.
so our waste is growing the cost of
disposing of the waste is growing we're
doing the best we can with the staff and
the tools we have in place but we can't
manage this on our own we're going to
have to rebuild our entire recycling
facility in a couple of years and we had
budgeted 112 000 in the capital
Improvement plan A couple of years ago
we all know now that there's no way
we're going to rebuild that facility
with the way costs have changed in 2025
for a hundred and twelve thousand so we
are really interested in these top goals
from the new Solid Waste Management plan
which has Source reduction at the top
it's always been at the top it just
hasn't happened
and we would be very excited and and
happy to participate in discussions
about how that Source reduction can
happen in the best way for New Hampshire
understanding that we're not advocating
duplicating what Maine did or Oregon or
any other state but
please help us
um we can't do it on our own and yeah
it's a consumer problem but it's also a
town problem
I appreciate that perspective thank you
representative Contour
foreign
thank you madam chair
um just a couple of observations based
on the discussions
um one is
if we start this commission I'm assuming
it's going to go for
probably a decade at least based on what
I'm hearing
because we're talking you know several
years
the commission won't probably get
started until 2023 late 2023 sometime
and so part of my concern is and I do
sit on another commission so I'm well
aware of how they operate
um
and basically
the commission looks at everything but
then it's another year before
legislation even becomes introduced if
there's anything that needs to be done
um
so although I'm not opposed to a
commission I do have some mixed feelings
about that that is that if this is such
an important issue that needs to be
addressed
say immediately sooner rather than later
um that the legislative approach
um might be more viable and getting
things done quicker from a legislative
perspective and I just wanted to make
that just make that comment thank you
I would I would like to hear sort of
some thoughts around uh
the time frame that a commission might
um take and if if representative evil
you're welcome to speak to that again I
I
though the program itself might take a
decade to implement I I am hopeful that
a commission would not go for 10 years
but let's I would love to hear your
thoughts okay I have I have many
thoughts
um one thing I just want to say is you
know whether the whether the ENA
recommends this for further uh
legislation or not
the solid waste working group will be
meeting I believe on the 28th and we're
going to be talking about some of the
things that we're going to be focusing
on
um and so if more legislation is
introduced in November and then you
start talking about it in January you're
going to have a pretty good idea at that
point what we're focusing on I'm sorry I
I can't be
better about the timing of all of this
but
um representative comtwa is right I mean
I I was Deputy speaker a couple of years
ago I know how long appointments take I
will say that commissions just take a
lot longer to get going because when you
have individuals from all different
walks of life you've got to identify
them
um
and legislative study committees just
get going a lot faster and you can have
you can have everybody there you can
request I mean people will believe me if
they're interested they will be there
and you can
um I I did this once before actually in
the dyslexia context where we kind of
created a working group around our
legislative study committee the only
other thing I'm going to say is that
every
study committee or commission that you
create on this issue you're getting Des
involved and Des is already short
staffed and it's pretty much always the
same people that have to be sitting here
that are working on legislation that are
doing the implementation plans that are
you know advising the solid waste
working group and then just doing the
basic work of of running the solid waste
Bureau so you know it's hard as I say I
had a lot of thoughts but I don't know
if that's helpful or not but
anyway that's what I would have to say
no I appreciate that representative and
then I will
thank you madam chair thank you uh for
taking my question
um would you would a possibility be is
to do like another working group like us
on or like underneath the solid waste
working group to you know establish like
take so many people and put it under
that to focus on different aspects
um as opposed to starting a commission
where you could just focus on the epr
side of things
um you know I'm thanks for mentioning
that I hadn't actually thought about
that but when we were kind of breaking
down
um how we were going to tackle advising
Des on the solid waste um plan we did
break down into subcommittees so that's
that's one one way that we could go
um
so I mean it's just
I wish I could be more definitive on
what the working group is going to do
but we have to meet and we have to
discuss this um the other thing is that
under the terms of the statute the
working group has to introduce or
present an interim report by November
30th I don't know how detailed that's
going to be because the bulk of our work
really had to do with helping out with
the long-range plan
but we might reflect some of our
priorities in that report so there's a
lot of there's a lot of things going on
but of course you have to make your
recommendation by
November 1st good luck
representative thank you the question I
had is in Maine Oregon does anybody
anybody who knows this please shout out
but um shout out to it but did they
start with a
study Commission
okay
sure
and the reason I'm wondering is it would
maybe it would be useful to find out who
may have started with a study Commission
because there's going to be a report
from that study commission I'm just
looking at instead of everybody
Reinventing the wheel Perhaps Perhaps
there's some really Germaine data in
their study commission report that that
sort of can answer some of the basic
questions that that we might be looking
at in a commission so then at that point
maybe that the looking at the problem
gets a lot smaller and we could do that
within the context that we have or not
maybe there's still a need for a study
commission but I'm looking at how do we
not reinvent the Wheel from from process
one look at what somebody else possibly
has and then be able to tailor that
I did speak with a senator from Maine
that sponsored this legislation and I
not 100 positive because this was a
conversation quite long ago when I have
to dig through my notes I believe they
did start with the study commission
however and it was a long process which
is why she said the sooner we get
started here
the sooner we can start actually
tackling this problem
and and I guess I know she'd be open to
further conversation sure sure and I
wondered is that something that is a is
that something that is a viable
possibility is starting with their
before we ask for a study commission
maybe maybe we start by asking is there
is there data in in somebody else's
commission report that basically covers
covers we're talking things outside of
New Hampshire here so these will some of
these answers will all be very Universal
together that states share yes sir yes I
I think that that we don't want to read
about the wheel I totally agreement on
that however I think that the solutions
that New Hampshire needs are probably
different than the one maybe not so
different than Maine but definitely
different than California and Oregon I
think that we could
probably benefit from getting
stakeholder interest from the people who
are here in New Hampshire
so that's why I mean I think that
looking other study commissions would be
of Paramount importance at the same time
I think we have to ask who's looking at
them and I think a study commission
would be the most appropriate venue for
that because then you have all the
stakeholders together
that's my personal opinion do you uh
does anybody think that
that some of this information if you
start at a point of like say this much
knowledge don't you think at that point
then the structures that we have and
again I'm not trying to debate whether a
study commission or not I'm not trying
to throw shade on that I'm just trying
to ask this question
do you think that if we got a leg up by
looking at some of the data that's out
there already that it would give the
existing resources that we have the
existing agency in the existing Solid
Waste Management Group
the ability they need then to call in
the New Hampshire stakeholders and get
their information I mean we could be
instead of starting from a position of
down here could that help us start from
a position of middle
thank you so
um Madam chair yes okay absolutely thank
you sorry
um you know as as part of our uh kind of
getting going with the solid waste
working group I actually invited in
folks from uh uh like the Des
counterparts in Vermont Massachusetts
and Maine and
um there is a discussion that was
recorded with the head of the solid
waste group I think her name is Pamela
Clark in Maine on what they've been
doing
um
on epr among other things so that's
already there
I'm trying to remember if I asked
I wanted to put a link to what Maine had
done on our website on the waste working
group website I don't know if we did my
recollection
is that there was a a study commission
at the legislative level they made
certain recommendations but I
I don't know
I thought that what they did was they
turned it over kind of to the Des in
Maine to make legislative
recommendations that that I'm looking at
the chair she's nodding I don't know
thank you uh representative that's
correct and there's a certain amount of
of
post the
um study commission that did happen in
the state of Maine a lot of what was
hashed out was set forth in rule making
right so I I am aware that there there
was a commission in Maine there are
other programs moving forward and there
are other pieces of legislation working
through legislatures in Massachusetts
and New York respectively currently on
this subject
um
so with that you know I do I to your
point it is a very it looks like there
are several different ways we can think
about
how best to move forward with the time
given but at the same point I do think
that this is a very complex issue that
would require a dedicated set of eyes
and stakeholders involved in the
conversation now how we do that and how
we arrive at that might be different
whether it's a committee a piece of
legislation or a commission that Still
Remains to be seen I
and if there is anybody else sitting
here I know there's people watching
intently over here so if you have other
thoughts you're welcome to contribute as
well
director wimsat is there anything else
that you have that you would like to
sort of communicate with us regarding
the ability for the Department to be
involved in such a commission would you
feel that the department would have
bandwidth to do so
uh thank you it's a very fair question
and the reality is that that every study
commission or committee that we either
sit on and in a way it doesn't matter
this particular bill doesn't put the es
on the committee commission it puts a
waste management council member on the
commission but it doesn't really matter
because we're always we always have to
be there and whether we sit on the
commission or we actually just come and
testify and provide information it is a
and and all of those are valuable and
valid and important but as
representative evil indicated
um we do get stretched then sometimes on
you know particularly when there are
multiple commissions so um as I said I'm
not sure it's Des role to say whether
the right way to do this is with a
commission or to try to have the solid
waste working group um handle it as well
what I will tell you is that you know
we've got a brand new Solid Waste
Management plan that absolutely
identifies extended producer
responsibility as something that we need
to explore through legislation I do
think that it's a topic that it isn't
you know at some level it's sort of
obvious yeah if you if you do that
that's going to help right it's going to
it's going to mean that the producers
are going to have some kind of and takes
different shapes and forms but the
producers will have some kind of
responsibility to take pressure off of
municipalities which end up managing a
lot of the waste so in in a general
sense yes it it makes sense that you say
why do we need a commission but the
reality is that it differs for different
products and materials and it's
complicated there's and there's a lot of
moving parts right now a lot of States
you know New Hampshire has in a general
sense not been a leader on extended
producer responsibility although I will
correct that
um with one thing that we were actually
significant leaders on going way back to
the to the turn of the Millennium
um the interstate Mercury education
reduction Clearinghouse New Hampshire
was instrumental in working with the
other northeast states and in the
Canadian provinces to identify um
ways to get Mercury out of products
Mercury added products and that has been
an amazing success story with that I the
the interstate uh Mercury and education
reduction Clearinghouse which is known
as imerc
um is run currently by the Northeast
Waste Management officials Association
which is an association of the eight uh
six New England states and and two in
New York and New Jersey
um that gets I I sit on their board as a
represented for New Hampshire and uh
numoa is a small But Mighty organization
that that actually implements that that
program and it and it provides for
um using the laws that have been passed
across the States including in New
Hampshire for folks to producers to
identify Mercury content in their
products and and make sure that they're
working to get it out and when they
don't to have collection programs such
as for mercury thermostats so there's a
lot of history there and New Hampshire
was a leader on that in more recent
years other New England States in
northeastern in States across the
country have been a lot more active than
New Hampshire has on other extended
producer responsibility activities you
know in some respects in New Hampshire
we've really benefited from uh others
being the Laboratories for that and then
when it gets a little more mature and
it's working pretty well uh we we try to
jump on that and I think that can happen
certainly for epr I think there's a lot
going on a lot of states are learning
things right now but at the very least
even if we don't have a particular new
product that we impose an extended
producer responsibility law for we
should at least be educating both our
legislators and the communities in Des
on how it works how it can work and as
we move forward throughout the
implementation of our 10-year plan we
would certainly hope and expect that
there will be
legislation that will provide for
extended producer responsibility
programs where appropriate for various
products and we think that that is
absolutely going to be a important
component of our overall attack on this
problem of reducing waste
thank you madam chair and thank you
director
one is it possible for you to send us
that update a report that was just done
on the waste reduction or is there a
spot we can find that you mean the solid
waste
absolutely as a matter of fact it's on
our website and we did I believe it was
sent to the chair of your committee by
memo probably probably with a link
rather that we're trying not to do as
much paper so it was probably a link but
I'll be happy to you if I can tell you
the quickest way to do it is is just to
go to our website and click on the solid
we go to the solid waste page and
there's the link there to that entire
report okay um we'll make sure that this
committee
um has all that information well thank
you for that and one other thing um is
there an epr association you had
mentioned about an association about
something else and is there an epr
association that is working together in
the New England states on how to go
forward with a lot of these issues
yes there so so I mentioned new MOA and
then there's also an organization called
nerc or other uh Northeast uh recycling
Council which we in nemoa Works closely
we have an agreement to work closely on
these kinds of issues as a matter of
fact this is one of the issues we're
working on with them and there's also a
and the name is going to escape me at
the moment
it's a
it's a broader Association that is
includes a lot of Industry groups and
Scott Castle do you know the name
no it's a it's it's actually focused
specifically on producer responsibility
I just can't remember the name of it so
the answer is yes there are a few
organizations in that category and I'll
also note just because I think it's it's
relevant you know obviously pfas is
something that is on the minds of a lot
of people right now and um I recently I
attended in September our quarterly
board meeting for numoa and the board at
that meeting agreed to authorize numoa
and the Moa staff to begin working on a
Model legislation for pfas epr and and
so that's something that
um you know it's going to take some time
but that's the kind of thing that really
can be helpful one of the one of the
problems that is a problem for States
because it you know if every state
develops a somewhat unique epr law for a
particular material
um and then they have to go and
Implement that it can be pretty
um just in terms of on on the agency
when it comes time to launch something
like that it can have an impact you need
staff to do that you need it could be a
lot of work up front to set up something
like that and one of the things that has
happened over the years and it's true
with that mercury example I gave you is
that when the northeast states agree on
model legislation that's going to be
implemented across the region or in some
cases across the country then you can
start to get
um sort of economies of scale you don't
you don't have to each state doesn't
have to invent their own program and a
lot of these epr programs require some
kind of notification and record keeping
that can be very costly and time
consuming for individual states and one
of the things that is likely to happen
they're going to look at models such as
there's another organization I hate to
keep hitting you with acronyms but
called ic2 which is the Interstate
Chemicals Clearinghouse and that is a
National Organization doesn't have full
membership across the states but has a
number of northeast states and States
across the country that have extended
producer responsibility and toxics and
packaging laws associated with
particular containments in packaging or
in products and the idea is that this
model legislation that pneumo will work
on along with the Northeast Recycling
Council that we're going to be working
in tandem went down will actually try to
be modeled after what we did with the
Mercury program and it would ideally set
up a system where the ic2 the Interstate
Chemicals Clearinghouse which has a lot
of infrastructure for collecting
information and receiving reports from
manufacturers
that could set up you know that I can
Envision and what we're expecting is
that legislation would set up a system
where
if New Hampshire and other states adopt
a law that that provides for pfas and
packaging or P fast and products uh
extended producer responsibility all the
manufacturers could report directly to
the ic2 group and they would cover their
reporting requirements for all the
states that were members instead of
having to report to each individual
State and having to develop a separate
reporting format so instead of having
this Mosaic of laws that become very
difficult for uh industry and and
business to comply with which also makes
it hard to pass those laws in the
legislature you have a system that's
much more attractive if you talk to any
member of Industry that's facing some
kind of a law that will require them to
either get something out of their
product or report about it they'll
always tell you the first and foremost
thing they're most concerned about is
having a 50-state mosaic of laws they
have to comply with and if they've got
something that's uniform across at least
a region or the nation it's much more
attractive it's much easier easier to
get industry on board with that and then
Caesar to pass those laws and get them
implemented and once you do pass them
it's much easier on the individual
states for implementation because
they're not all individually standing up
these individual infrastructures for
managing the reporting and the
regulation
uh just one
thing that we might be able to have some
discussions among ourselves so go ahead
I was just going to comment based off
what you're saying that that's kind of
to the point where I was trying to go
with if we do have some things to look
at in Maine right now doesn't that give
us a leg up on a lot of our
our our Research into this absolutely I
will say that anything that New
Hampshire Des has ever done successfully
when it comes to a new initiative we've
always learned a lot from other states
that have unless we're doing it unless
we're the first ones there's almost
always somebody who's done what you're
trying to do we always go to that and
we're not shy about stealing good ideas
so with
with it we have I I think you sort of
helped clarify some things for me with
the um with mentioning namoa and ic2 I
think that there are
a broad range of scenarios that need to
be looked at with regard to epr and I
think that it is important that we get
it right we're hearing from many
stakeholders who are here today as well
as in the previous in previous uh with
representative partials
um
initial presentation of the bill with to
our committee that perhaps we we need to
continue to have this conversation and
though we can't make a recommendation
today because there is not a quorum I
would like to schedule we have a
deadline for the committee I know we're
meeting again October 25th as a full
committee so I can certainly schedule
something between now and then to make a
recommendation to the full committee and
I would like to do that I think it's
important that we have that opportunity
to
um
through the appropriate venue do that so
there there will be no recommendation
made today and with that
um I thank you for your time and your
attention and I think
um that we can all agree that there's a
lot to still discuss around the extended
producer responsibility so with that I
will close the meeting out it's 11 30 in
the morning thank you